[Music]
welcome to part 6 of your training let's
meet the device you'll be working with
this is Polybius on the outside it may
look like an ordinary arcade cabinet but
on the inside polybius holds advanced
surveillance systems perfect for
tracking user behavior careful users may
experience some slight side effects the
polybius machine the future of covert
surveillance between the 1950s and 1970s
the CIA was experimenting with
alternative ways to weaken the enemy the
program was called project MKULTRA the
CIA tested on unaware subjects using
hypnosis and psychoactive drugs in order
to find the perfect interrogation method
in 1976 the secret program was exposed
to the public
the revelation spurred countless
conspiracy theories that film producers
were quick to pull from movies like
wargames in The Last Starfighter
combined paranoia thrills and video game
sensibilities but movies weren't the
only things inspired by MKULTRA beyond
the theater marquees one of the biggest
videogame urban legends was brewing and
it all started with a mysterious arcade
cabinet that suddenly appeared in the
quiet town of Portland
[Music]
this is Logan Boden's I am director of
operations here at quarter world arcade
in Portland Oregon Logan
loves urban legends oh yeah I love them
and he's kind of become a connoisseur of
the weird and wonderful myths from
Portland's past I've been gathering the
local lore as Portland goes you quickly
learn a lot about what Portland was and
the folklore that surrounds it folk more
like Polybius Portland's most infamous
legend which he learned about while
watching TV with a friend
we were watching The Simpsons episode
that has the poly bits in the background
and he started laughing and had no idea
what he was talking about so he filled
me in the legend of polybius the short
and skinny of it is around 1981 this
arcade cabinet appeared in a few arcades
and the outskirts of Portland
now if you played this game it was said
that you would have seizures fits of
amnesia night terrors and also just a
complete desire to continue playing this
game so why would someone inadvertently
create a video game that had all these
effects perhaps it was on purpose
supposedly every couple of weeks these
strange men and black suits would show
up and they wouldn't take any money out
of the machines they would just open up
the back
supposedly maybe taking some readings of
data perhaps a continuation of MKULTRA
and then after about two months just as
mysteriously as they appeared poof
disappeared and I've never been seen
since and so a myth was born and with it
came a legion of believers and skeptics
trying to decipher fact from fiction
this is Brian Dunning he makes a living
debunking outlandish stories and has
heard many tall tales so Brian tell us
why the story of polybius was a little
different it turned out kind of much to
my surprise that just about every piece
of evidence supporting the story was
true first two kids actually did get
knocked out playing video games in
Portland Oregon in 1981 second ten days
after that the government actually was
raiding arcades and taking games out
third we know the games were used by the
government for training
and finally there was a game called poly
play it was a case where this game was
physically removed from every arcade in
which it existed so it seems like all
the pieces of the puzzle exist leading
to a confirmation of the legend right
Brian arcade culture is extensively
documented they had trade magazines they
had consumer magazines and in all of
those issues throughout the entire 1980s
there is not a single mention anywhere
of a game called Polybius we know for a
fact that it did not exist but
proprietors of The Legend weren't quite
willing to let the myth die
so they began to design different
elements of the game themselves
schoolteacher and dedicated arcade
builder Paul Santa Cruz is working hard
on bringing the legend to life
[Music]
one day it kind of popped in my head you
know what I'm gonna make a plebian
but how exactly do you make a Polybius
well in 2007 an underground community of
gamers actually developed a hypnotic
video game and marquee graphics inspired
by the myth it's what they thought the
game could actually look like Paul
decided to take the work one step
further and build a fully custom arcade
cabinet
everything was there that I needed the
graphics were there the game was there
so maybe the cabinet wanted to exist in
real space and time
[Music]
I wanted people to see it and stop and
turn to their friend and say wait a
minute is that really it
I wanted it to be part of that mythos
[Music]
so there you have it the story of how a
video game legend became an arcade
reality I don't think it matters at all
that the legend is true or false it's
just a fun thing to follow I had a lot
of people tell me the cabinet was cool
and didn't have any interest in playing
it because they weren't gamers but they
loved the fact that this thing existed
if Polybius didn't exist it does now -
the seizures in amnesia you're not gonna
like be a sleeper cell or are you
[Music]